[Musique]
vous êtes surprise wild cat et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'afrique à la une ce soir j - 2 avant
l'ouverture de la 33e édition de la
coupe la fée des nations nous irons au
cameroun afin de vous faire vivre
l'effervescence du football qui envahit
peu à peu le pays et ceci malgré la
pandémie et les problèmes de sécurité
les instructeurs russes qui sont aux
côtés de l'armée malienne sont ils
membres de la société privée wagner ou à
park est il à l'armée russe et que
signifient leur présence dans le pays et
pour la lutte contre le terrorisme
éléments de réponses et explications
avec notre spécialiste
oici menace
notre invité de ce vendredi et joël
akaffou un jeune réalisateur ivoirien
prometteurs dont le premier film
documentaire long métrage est
actuellement dans les salles en france
après avoir marqué fespaco traversée est
un récit nuancé sur l'immigration en
suivant un candidat aussi irritant
qu'attachant
ce dimanche s'ouvre au cameroun pour un
mois la 33e édition de la can 2021 un
événement très attendu où les 24
meilleures sélections africaines de
football vont s'affronter malgré le coc
vides et les problèmes de sécurité
l'effervescence gagne peu à peu le pays
suivez ce reportage de nos
correspondants à yaoundé où se jouera le
match d'ouverture entre le cameroun et
le burkina faso richard au nez on à
l'ena et stéphanois
au son de l'accord de la plus connue
d'afrique les vendeurs tentent d'attirer
les passants dans ce grand marché de
yaoundé parée aux couleurs de la can
entre maillot chapeau drapeaux et autres
gars des sept femmes des lions
indomptables a fait son choix
[Musique]
à quelques kilomètres du marché central
une autre quête celle des tickets
d'accès pour le match d'ouverture il
faut se rendre dans un point de vente
comme ici à la mairie de yaoundé 2 les
tickets sont partis comme des petits
pains plus de mille vendu la veille au
grand dam de ses supporters ça fait deux
jours et sèche d'avoir entité
et là le maire de nant numéro j'attends
depuis le matin a pas encore des tickets
en attendant mon ticket je sais déjà les
conditions qu'il faut pour être au stade
et c'est qu'il faut être vaccinés il
faut avoir un test de ddr date en moins
de 48 heures pour ceux qui ne pourront
pas entrer dans les stades des fanzone
comme celle ci en plein coeur de la
ville de yaoundé ont été créés dans les
préparatifs pour jacquet bogueys et
équipe cet espace recevra entre deux et
trois mille personnes chaque jour
nous sommes en train de préparer la
scène par rapport à la can bien sûr
parce qu'on aura une projection des
matches ici bien évidemment avec
quelques spectacles entre les matches et
même les jours y aura pas d moitié
méfiez-vous du wacken monteux
progressivement dans les rues de yaoundé
une fièvre dans le pic est attendu ce
dimanche au stade paul mba lors du match
d'ouverture opposant le cameroun au
burkina faso
on passe au mali ou le médiateur de la
cedeao était en visite pour transmettre
un message goodluck johnatan est venu
dire au chef de la junte ac milan ita
que les cinq années proposé pour la
transition n'était pas recevable ce
déplacement est un point d'étape avant
le sommet extraordinaire des chefs
d'état de la sous-région qui se tiendra
ce dimanche 9 janvier à accra
et on reste au mali pour évoquer cette
information que nous confirmions déjà
hier concernant la présence des
militaires russes dans le pays et à
tombouctou précisément ils seraient une
cinquantaine installé aux côtés de
l'armée malienne et il serait issu de la
société privée wagner ou de l'armée
russe notre collègue wahaha ci menace
spécialiste des mouvements jihadistes
qui a suivi cette information pour nous
nous explique la différence est pourquoi
les autorités russes maintiennent le
flou on écoute un contact avec la minus
ma la présence dans le nord tombouctou
pareil il y aura un contact avec la
minus mas et encore une fois on revient
à ceux à ce dilemme 6 et des mercenaires
la minus ma voudra pas traiter avec eux
parce que ce n'est pas un état 6 et 10
militaires russes il y aura une mise en
place de ce qu'on appelle en tas milite
à une des complications ça veut dire des
procédés de coordination qui éviterait
les bavures les couacs entre les deux
armées par exemple s'il ya un convoi de
la minus main les rues seront seraient
informés et vice versa on a vu ça par
exemple en syrie où l'aviation aérienne
l'aviation russe et présenter à des
complications avec les français avec les
américains etc mais dans ce cas là ça
serait reconnaître de fait l'influencé
et la présence russe de la part des
occidentaux et de l'onu et d'un autre
côté la reconnaissance aussi de la part
de moscou et de bamako de cette présence
russie est un message de soutien
l'adresse du seul otages français dans
le monde le journaliste olivier dubois
et depuis neuf mois entre les mains d'un
groupe djihadiste au mali sa famille a
mis en ligne une pétition sur challenge
point org pour demander sa libération et
déplore l'absence d'information et de
silence des autorités maliennes et
françaises sur ce dossier
passe à l'est de la rdc où trois agents
nous angie concern worldwide ont été
kidnappés ce vendredi dans les parcs ou
les environs du parc national environ
d'après de goma d'après une source
locale le drame s'est produit aux
environs de 10 heures du matin heure
locale alors que cette équipe revenait
d'une mission humanitaire les habitants
de cette zone s'inquiètent de la
persistance de l'insécurité sur ce
tronçon et appelle le gouvernement à
renforcer les mesures de sécurité on les
écoute ou micro de justin comme
l'insécurité persiste en ce temps cela
nous ne savons pas quoi
et pourtant lorsque le gouvernement a
décrété l'état de siège il nous avait
assuré que la sécurité allait être
surpris car l'insécurité persiste sur la
route ça kekova
d'une ong qui a été ciblée
fois arrivé dans ce tronçon personnes
dans le véhicule ont été quittes masisi
aux catalans oui
la population
de prendre ses responsabilités
nous avons besoin de sécurité c'est
qu'ils dépassent que si
la buse et la sécurité un accroc à
d'agneau ghassan ghosn a dit si
nous avons peur que les kidnappings
continue ici
il ya quelques jours beaucoup d'autres
humanitaire ont été enlevés à quelques
kilomètres d'ici sur la route de saké il
y avait des congolais et un blanc avec
eux on les a emmenés dans la brousse
malheureusement nous ne savons pas la
suite avec waka est beau jeu rapide
comme il faut
ce vendredi a marqué les célébrations du
noël orthodoxe en ethiopie et notamment
à lalibela cette ville en région a marre
a connu pour ses églises creusées dans
la roche les forces tigréenne ont occupé
cette ville pendant plusieurs mois avant
de se retirer vers le titre et
mi-décembre l'occasion pour des milliers
d'orthodoxes d'effectuer le traditionnel
pèlerinage de noël malgré une forte
présence militaire
chaque année des milliers de fidèles
affluent autour des églises de lalibela
pour la veillée du noël orthodoxe
mais cette fois ci la cérémonie est
particulière il y à un mois encore cette
ville en région amara était occupé par
les rebelles tigréens pendant près de
cinq mois les habitants sont restés
cloîtrés chez eux en raison de la
présence des tigres et 1 et de leurs
actions à lalibela nous ne savions pas
si nous pourrions célébrer noël je suis
très content de voir autant d'affluence
est de pouvoir célébrer cette fête avec
beaucoup de personnes pour notre
communauté cela va au delà
les églises troglodyte de lalibela sont
classés au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco et accueille en temps normal
des touristes du monde entier les aînés
et son mari ont veillé jusqu'au petit
matin ils ont fait le voyage depuis les
etats-unis répondant à un appel du
gouvernement à la diaspora éthiopienne
bout des doigts la tossée nous voulons
voir à quel point l'équipe i est un
endroit sûr en plus de cela des
personnes honteux des cibles et des
bâtiments ont été détruits par le tplf
donc cela va prendre du temps mais nous
sommes ici pour aider ponctuellement
mais aussi à l'avenir jusqu'à ce que les
choses reviennent à la normale
si la guerre a fait des ravages dans le
nord de l'ethiopie lalibela a été
relativement épargnée mais les habitants
restent malgré tout marqué par les
violences et intimidations et les
pénuries de nourriture d'électricité ou
encore de médicaments la vie reprend
mais pour certains l'heure n'est pas
encore à la fête fall alors j'ai encore
peur je ne me sens pas heureux il ya des
rumeurs qui disent qu'ils vont bientôt
revenir autour du village de la mer ils
ont fait beaucoup de mal ils ont même
essayé de tuer mon petit frère
si les forces tigréenne se sont retirés
des régions amara et à fars le conflit
est loin d'être terminé des frappes
aériennes ont été reportées au tigré
alors que la région toujours
inaccessible peine à survivre avec peu d
aide humanitaire
voilà pour ce reportage de marie a guère
nicolescu nous parlons cinéma ce soir
avec le réalisateur ivoirien joël
akaffou hauteur de traverser son premier
long métrage documentaire prix spécial
au fespaco ce film nous propose un
regard lucide sur les jeunes immigrés
qui tentent la traversée de l'afrique
vers l'europe avant de passer l'extrait
j'aimerais jouer la caf ou dites nous
qu'est ce qui vous a motivé à faire le
cinéma je rappelle que vous avez étudié
à ouagadougou
et maxi à 2 ce qui m'a motivé à fait du
cinéma déjà il faut dire que j'ai avant
d'être dabou j'ai appelé la dramatique
j'ai eu une maîtrise en art dramatique
aline sak nou côte d'ivoire il s'est tu
pendant mes études on a dramatic que l'
envie de faire du cinéma est arrivé il a
fini mes études j'ai obtenu une bourse
d'études et à qui je suis allé à
ouagadougou apprendre le métier qui me
passionnait le plus alors on comprend
bien dans ce film justement l'envié
l'importance de montrer la réalité de ce
que vivent aussi vos compatriotes les
ivoiriens je vous propose de voir un
extrait simplement de la bande annonce
du film et on parle juste après
saison villas
c'est pas une vie mais angoua jo j'ai dû
là
tout le monde et l'une ici en europe si
la valeur des marques à toulouse - c'est
pas à nous seulement tombe au bénin au
libye
on l'a vu dans cet extrait joël la mer
qu'on ne voit pas là dans cette extrême
mais qui joue un rôle important dans le
destin de ces jeunes lui dit au
personnage principal n'oublie pas
pourquoi tu es parti dites-nous au fond
pourquoi est ce qu'il est parti ce jeune
un ca junior touré alias bourgeois
pourquoi at il quitté la côte d'ivoire
pour se rendre en france au péril de sa
vie parce qu'il traverse et la libye
l'italie jusqu'en france
eux ils bougent moins pâti tout est
parti de la côte d'ivoire pas pour la
tour eiffel il est parti de la côte
d'ivoire pape ou la neige il est parti
de la côte d'ivoire pas plus haut
building français non il est venu en
france ou avoir de quoi aider sa famille
qui qui va de mal en pis depuis le décès
le décès de son défunt frère est venu
comme lady dans les premières séquences
du film le dit un héros égale à 6 ans et
quand saint fons et femme et du couple
bourgeois si travail du en france avec
30000 euros il peut se construit une bac
en côte d'ivoire où doit loger sa
famille il est venu parce qu'ils
cherchaient ils cherchent un avenir
meilleur contre tous les autres noms qui
viennent en europe alors ce film est
aussi très politique
les jeunes disent qu'ils partent parce
qu'ils n'ont pas d'avenir sur place quel
est votre message à vous autant à
l'adresse de ces jeunes qu'à l'adresse
des politiciens et des politiciens
africains en particulier
j'ai donné mon message revenez d'abord à
l'endroit de ces jeunes
s'est dit quand on part on fuit et quand
on fuit on ne change rien au fait le
fait de parti ne changera rien il tant
que vous partez de génération pâtiront
il ne changera pas d'autres c'est de
réussir merci merci beaucoup joël
akaffou d'être venu dans ce journal de
l'afrique pour nous parler de ce film
traversé c'est ainsi que nous refermons
ce journal l'afrique merci à tous ceux
qui nous unit de bobo dioulasso à
abidjan en passant par bamako rester
avec nous car l'actualité continue sur
france 24
[Musique]